From the chat, just getting up and running and didn't get a question in early or have the opportunity to search prior Q&A. Sorry, that's okay.
I don't know some of the programs I wish to run on the right say they need a bone like the hammerball other than the hammerball.
Okay, so just ignore them. So you have a hammerball. Is the QX2 bulb a better bulb? No. Is the QX2 bulb stronger if you put it right up to your skin? Yes.
Is the QX2 bulb for the purpose of putting it right up next to your skin? No.
The QX2 bulb is for putting it on a stand to use during the day so you can walk around the house and it will go out a little bit farther and you'll get a little bit more benefit.
Do you need the QX2 bulb? No. Do I even recommend the QX2 bulb? Almost never. Now they have the hammer, the jackhammer. If you want to use it during the day and you want to walk around, but still it's only going to really go out 8 to 10 feet.
So do I suggest you even get that? No. If you call true rife, are they going to try to sell you all these things? Probably. So personally, I only use the hammerball.
So just that's what I would suggest. Unless you're going to like do some of the facial programs and you want to get that zinger of all that is that is involved. You're putting like some some different nutrients on your skin and you're using the bulb on your, if you're doing a specific purpose like that, then yeah, you could get that zinger of all.
But only that I wouldn't use anything but the hammer bulb personally.
That's it you could ignore just because they have a different bulb in the picture doesn't need anything.
And just because they have it in the right up. It's just that's what they were using when it was rich enough. So don't worry about that.